Mariah Carey may have just worn her most  risque outfit yet the pop diva stepped  out in Las Vegas Saturday night walking  the red carpet in this for her first DJ  gig at 1oak mariah wore all black  flaunting her figure in a course said  sexy fishnet tights and leather jacket  leaving very little to the imagination  mimi bared her butt with her bust nearly  spilling out as she posed pinup style at  the event and the singer was dripping  with diamonds including a sparkly  necklace and bedazzled butterfly ring  just me I can't help it and I witnessed  lzt the 49 year old headed straight to  the DJ booth to join her pal BJ's us one  safe to say Mariah pulled out all the  stops for disappearance and we are  obsessed with this sultry look